it was a night like any other night
except here I was climbing the Platonic
Peaks like Romeo on a second date well I
was there for the Dame she had eyes like
imaginary numbers and curves that went
on forever said she wanted to go home
said I could help
said the pay was good didn't say
anything about climbing a mousse there
many brought private I what are you
doing here a pretty number sent me to
find a stolen Vegas well to enter the
cave you must answer my riddles three
what was it with riddles and why they
always come in threes is it an egg no
why would it be an egg it's usually an
egg what can i hold in my hand but has
zero area is it a dodo egg it's not an
egg I took out the rock that had nearly
brained me before and gave it a hard
ponder the size of the rising bump on my
conk said to me that this thing had area
and a lot of it but what if I coughed
out a triangle from this side here as
any Mook could see this triangle had a
quarter of the area of the full triangle
I did the same thing again with each of
the smaller triangles again a quarter of
the remaining area gone and I just kept
going after an infinite number of cuts I
was satisfied that my triangle had zero
area a bounded shape with zero area now
it's not often that I surprise myself
but my own two myths have created
something crazy and new very good hmm
now show me a shape with finite area but
an infinitely long perimeter let me get
this straight if I were to make a snip
in the border of this shape smooth it
out and lay it on the it would go on for
each one through then you can talk it
would go on forever are you through yeah
so show me that shape then hmm I had
been miss stuck since the Rubik's Cube
Fiasco of 58 all the shapes I knew had
perimeters circles 2pi are triangles
some of their sides what's this an angle
an angle from heaven what if I were to
pinch each side like so a third of the
way through just so and do it again and
again and again
after each pinch the perimeter got a
third longer because where there had
been three line segments now there were
four as for the area every pinch made
more triangles that's true but those
triangles were getting smaller and
smaller you could say that the area was
converging approaching a fixed number
while the perimeter was just getting
bigger and bigger uncontrollably
ballooning like an overindulgent
birthday clown after infinity pinches
flim-flam there it was finite area but
in finite perimeter now that is a piece
of work ooh you're good riddle three
show me a picture that if I magnify it
under my microscope
I'll keep seeing the original picture no
matter how much i zoom in you're a
strange little man
thank you I was out of ideas so I looked
at my muse my complex Dora who's the
dame and then it hit me she's a
heartbreaker my fractal femme fatale
what'd she do yes she'll do just fine it
was dark and at first I thought the cave
was empty but then I noticed the box the
daemon played me like a triangle she had
told me she wanted to go home
what she really wanted was to bring her
home here the fractals spread everywhere
most of them the same no matter how deep
you looked at him like tourism on some
had infinitely long perimeters others
were objects with no area or volume all
of them created through infinite
repetition so you wanted to know what
fractals are well kid they're the stuff
that dreams are made of
you